If you had the opportunity to go and view any culture from the past,
like if you can be completely invisible and walk around amongst the Romans or
cave people or native Americans before the Europeans came,
what would you choose?
Wow,
that's really hard question.
Yeah.
MMM.
The first time where anything was trying to be colonized,
like changed like the first time,
like a boat showed up in Polynesia or something like that and some white people
got out,
right?
We're used to being in the fields every day and this guy hunts and this guy
watches after the boys and teaches them and,
and then all of a sudden they come up and they're building like you guys need
to,
why you live in,
he calls for Color Cox are the women are staring at their fucking balls two feet
from the ground.
What are these things?
I,
they my,
what the fuck is going on price please guys.
Got To fucking look at his hair.
It's chunked off his fucking Tito.
He's got bones in his fucking air price.
Can I get a Bible
lesson?
And there was this thing called Noah's Ark.
Sit down.
He's fuckers.
Don't pay attention.
Get you fucking round them up.
Me and the boys,
we're going to need about 40 these fucking things.
Climb trees is your character's name.
I love the guy.
He needs to come back more often.
This is the kind of say,
Geez,
Joe,
they climb trees.